Sean are you afraid of running out of
content I mean don't you feel like you
have to have you have 365 days where you
sort of have to have something fresh and
new on the site yeah not really there's
every year there's about 10,000 films
made 4,000 are submitted to Sundance if
not more and so you know there's a lot
of stuff out there and not all of it
would fit well on our site but there's
there's plenty there's probably content
plus with technology the way it's moving
editing software becoming much cheaper
higher quality video cameras you know
you're starting to see better and better
movies unless and less budget so we
think that's just going to increase over
time and then what is this trend spotter
and do you find it to be an effective
perk yeah at times so the trendspotter
is our social discovery tool basically
what that is is we we encourage people
everybody likes to be the first to
discover movies books and music and you
know a lot of times with bands once a
man gets too big people say it's sold
out and they're no longer interested
anymore but if you could prove you're in
the 17th fan you want it to get as big
as possible we're tapping into that
vanity piece of it that people have
online so what we do is we quantify that
so with a fear of the first if you're
within the first five people to discover
a movie and purchase it we give you your
money back towards your next movie I'm
pre-screen so we're starting to see
people use that to share as they just as
they figure out what it is it's a new
concept but once the people who
understand what it is and it encourages
people to buy early and often and share
with their friends family and co-workers
and then talk about converting theater
lover consumers to online consumers you
know we think that they're in a
different bucket we think that people
who consume online will consume online
people who consume in a theater are
going to consume in the theater it's
really really hard to get somebody who
wants to consume online into a theater
and vice versa so the whole notion of
the windows although it does make sense
to some degree what you're doing is
you're alienating beyond
consumer and you know these people are
more connected the word spreads faster
you know I point2 melancholia that
Magnolia did and the success of that in
margin call in the success of that were
they did they end date or even a pre
theatrical it generated buzz and these
movies did awesome in theaters so I
wouldn't be surprised if we start to see